hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live wir brauchen China um die globalen
Probleme zu lösen das sagte der
EU-Außenbeauftragte Borrell heute kurz
bevor
eu-kommissionschefin von der Leyen zu
Gesprächen in Peking erwartet wird
morgen findet das statt und es ist ein
spannender Besuch weil von der Leyen
hatte letzte Woche in einer
Grundsatzrede zum Verhältnis zwischen EU
und China eins ganz deutlich gemacht
entscheidend für das zukünftige
Verhältnis mit der EU werde Chinas
Haltung gegenüber putinskrieg in der
Ukraine sein hat sie gesagt wir sehen
Bilder auch von diesem von dieser Rede
von letzter Woche die Beziehung zwischen
EU und China die sind aktuell
kompliziert und deswegen ist das Thema
bei uns heute was wird China in Zukunft
für uns sein wichtiger Handelspartner
oder Gegner das ist heute Thema bei uns
und auch heute dass es passiert der
französische Präsident macron ist in
Peking eingetroffen auch er wird bei dem
Treffen dabei dazwischen von der Leyen
und Titel und er ist heute schon
angereist es soll aber auch ein
Vier-Augen-Gespräch zwischen von der
Leyen und die geben Frankreich hofft
darauf mehrere wirtschaftsdeals
abzuschließen so ist da auch eine
Wirtschaftsdelegation dabei aber auch
macron will ein gutes Verhältnis oder
will das gute Verhältnis Chinas zu Putin
nutzen um eventuell damit eine
Vermittlerrolle Chinas zusammen zu
kriegen in Sachen russischer Krieg in
der Ukraine also das ist heute wirklich
ein spannendes Thema über das wir
sprechen wollen ihr merkt da wird
Diplomatie gefragt sein und es geht eben
mehr als nur um wirtschaftsstils
deswegen könnt ihr Fragen stellen direkt
im Stream mit kommentieren oder auch per
Mail und zuerst beantworten die unsere
beiden Korrespondenten in Brüssel und in
Peking Miriam Steiner und Florian
neuhahn hallo schön dass ihr dabei seid
hallo
Miriam macron und von der Leyen die
kommen mit konkreten Forderungen scheint
es ja fast so im Gepäck also sie wollen
eben dass China mehr Verantwortung
übernimmt um eine Friedenslösung zu
finden und können sie sich da jetzt
wirklich Hoffnung machen in China
die Signale die es bisher aus Peking
gibt die lassen nicht so viel Hoffnung
zu China sagt zwar immer wieder es hätte
eine neutrale Position und gehe jetzt
sich selbst als großer Vermittler aber
wenn man sich die Fakten anguckt dann
sieht das doch anders aus also da steht
Peking weiter fest am Putin Seite das
war vor ein paar Wochen ganz deutlich
als Putin zu als als ich zu Besuch bei
Putin in Moskau war während sich der
Westen gerade in Kiew die Klinke in die
Hand gibt was natürlich überraschen eine
Überraschung wäre wenn es doch endlich
zu einem Telefonat zwischen Staatschefin
und dem ukrainischen Präsidenten
selinski kommen würde bisher war das ja
nicht der Fall und der Chinas
Botschafter bei der EU sagte dazu gerade
in einem Interview die den Ping sei nun
mal sehr beschäftigt
danke Miriam und Florian wir haben ich
habe es kurz angesprochen Ursula von der
Leyen hat sich daher kritisch geäußert
in ihrer Grundsatzrede so hieß das auch
und wie ja wie groß ist denn die Sorge
der EU das China da also wirklich noch
näher an Russland dran rücken könnte in
der Zukunft
ich würde sagen die Sorge des gesamten
Westens ist da gerade sehr groß man
beobachtet diesen Schulterschluss den
Miriam auch gerade beschrieben hat sehr
intensiv die sind Staatsbesuch von hier
drei Tage lang in Moskau aber auch diese
gemeinsamen militärischen Übungen die
zwischen China und Russland gemeinsam
stattfinden und jetzt ist die große
Sorge dass China eine weitere rote Linie
überqueren könnte und das wäre erstmals
in diesem Konflikt auch Waffen an
Russland zu liefern für den Einsatz in
der Ukraine und heute war hier ein NATO
Außenminister treffen und danach hat der
Nato-Generalsekretär Jens deutenberg den
Tonfall noch mal deutlich verschärft er
hat gesagt sollte China Waffen liefern
an Russland dann wäre das ein Zitat
historischer Fehler der schwerwiegende
Konsequenzen nach sich ziehen würde
welche Konsequenzen das sein würden das
hat er nicht gesagt aber damit ist
sozusagen die Preisklasse gesetzt der
Tonfall ist verschärft man hofft mit
diesen drastischen Worten und diesen
Warnungen die man auch sicherlich morgen
persönlich dem chinesischen Staatschef
überbringen wird noch einmal China davon
abzuhalten aber die große Frage die sich
hier viele Stellen ist wie groß ist
eigentlich noch der Einfluss Chinas der
Einfluss Europas auf die chinesische
Staatsführung
klare Worte von der NATO aber eben auch
letzte Woche schon kritische Worte vorab
von Ursula von der Leyen du hast die
auch bei uns zusammengefasst in einem
Beitrag in dem wir mal kurz reinschauen
wollen so deutlich wie die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin hat noch kaum
jemand in politischer Verantwortung
Chinas Macht streben beschrieben
das klare Ziel der Kommunistischen
Partei Chinas ist ein systemischer
Wandel zu einer internationalen Ordnung
in denen Mittelpunkt china steht
im Mittelpunkt und an der Seite
Russlands ohne jegliche Kritik am
russischen Krieg wie zuletzt beim Besuch
von Staatspräsident key in Moskau Europa
müssen so von der Leyen seine
China-Politik daher neu ausrichten ein
Beispiel das Abkommen zum
Investitionsschutz auf das sich Europa
und China noch 2020 im Grundsatz
verständigt hatten von der Leyen will
das Abkommen neu bewerten übersetzt es
hat wohl keine Zukunft mehr Europa will
unabhängiger werden und bleibt doch
angewiesen auf China
Achtung Miriam was wird China näher sein
ein gutes Verhältnis zu Russland oder
ein gutes Verhältnis zur EU
das ist eine gute Frage bisher ist China
ja sehr groß darin genau diesen Spagat
zu schaffen und ich glaube das wird es
auch weiterhin probieren also weiter an
Putin Seite zu stehen aber auch nicht so
weit dass es den Westen zu sehr
verärgert das ist ja bisher die Position
und mit der fährt China auch ganz gut
denn China profitiert auch von dieser
Situation also wenn man sich zum
Beispiel anguckt die Sanktionen des
Westens gegen Russland da profitiert
China wirtschaftlich kauft günstig Öl
und Gas ein ist inzwischen der größte
Handelspartner Russland geworden und
profitiert von diesen Lücken also
chinesische Firmen stoßen in diese
Lücken vor die westliche Unternehmen
hinterlassen haben weil sie sich
zurückgezogen haben aus Russland und
diesen Spagat wie Florian ist eben auch
beschrieben hat also die roten Linien
des Westens nicht zu überschreiten aber
weiter auf beiden Seiten alles
mitzunehmen was irgendwie geht glaube
das wird China auch weiterhin machen
und Florian du hast eben in den Beitrag
erwähnt dass von der Leyen eben das
Abkommen für Investitionsschutz neu
bewerten möchte warum warum möchte sie
das warum ist das so
erstmal muss man glaube ich sagen dieses
Abkommen stammt aus einer anderen Zeit
quasi ist zwar nur drei Jahre alt
dezember 2020 war die Grundsatzeinigung
aber es hat sich in der Zwischenzeit
eben viele getan china hat mittlerweile
als quasi normales Mittel dass man
wirtschaftlichen Druck auf Staaten
ausübt um sie quasi zu erpressen für die
eigene Position zu sein und diesen
Wandel hat von der Leyen eben auch sehr
deutlich und als erster auch sehr
deutlich beschrieben in dieser Position
und darauf muss man eben Konsequenzen
ziehen jetzt ist es so dass dieses
Abkommen eigentlich seit längerem
bereits auf Eis lag nachdem im Frühjahr
2021 China einige EU ab Abgeordnete auf
seine Sanktionsliste gesetzt hat hat das
EU Parlament damals dieses Abkommen
gestoppt es gab aber immer wieder noch
die Hoffnung leise geäußert in einigen
europäischen Hauptstädten in Paris aber
wohl auch in Berlin dass man dieses
Abkommen wiederbeleben können
und dem hat von alleine nun eine Regel
vorgeschoben weil man eben nicht mehr
mit China auf Augenhöhe als ja eine für
einen gemeinsamen Wettbewerb sorgen kann
sondern man sieht jetzt China wirklich
als systemische Herausforderung und
einen gemeinsames Abkommen mit
gemeinsamen Regeln das ist wohl auf die
nächste Zeit auf mittelfristige Sicht
eher unwahrscheinlich geworden was beide
Länder in jedem Fall haben ist seit
vielen vielen Jahren enge
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen sind teilweise
auch voneinander abhängig wer wen aber
da mehr braucht dazu haben wir auch
einen Beitrag vorbereitet von Sophia
Diester und Petra Riffel schauen
gemeinsam rein
für Deutschland ist China seit Jahren
der wichtigste Handelspartner mehr als
245 Milliarden Euro waren es 2021 die
deutsche Wirtschaft ist also auf China
angewiesen
importiert werden vor allem
elektronische Geräte und deren
Komponenten aber auch Spielzeug und
Möbel sowie chemische Erzeugnisse für
die Industrie
fast die Hälfte der Deutschen
Industriefirmen benötigt wichtige
Vorleistungen aus China besonders die
Automobilbranche
umgekehrt importiert China auch viele
waren aus Deutschland
hauptsächlich Maschinen Autos und
Autoteile ebenso wie Elektrotechnik
für China ist Deutschland sogar der
wichtigste Partner innerhalb der EU denn
in Summe exportiert die Bundesrepublik
so viel wie die nächsten 10 EU-Länder
zusammen
[Musik]
Beispiel E-Auto für die Produktion in
der EU werden Teile aus
unterschiedlichen Ländern zugeliefert
viele davon aus China vor allem beim
Herzstück des Fahrzeugs der Batterie
zeigt sich die große Abhängigkeit ihre
Herstellung benötigt kritische Rohstoffe
wie beispielsweise Graphit dieses wird
zu 74% in China gefördert
aber nicht nur wichtige Rohstoffe
sondern auch komplette Batterien werden
importiert beispielsweise führte
Deutschland 2020 fast ein Drittel seiner
Lithium-Ionen-Batterien aus China ein
außerdem stellt China über 85% der
weltweiten Dauermagnete her die in
Elektromotoren verwendet werden
bricht die Lieferkette an einer dieser
Stellen ab kommt es zum Stillstand der
gesamten Produktion doch auch China ist
Abhängig vor allem bei Gütern und
Vorleistungen im Fahrzeug und
Maschinenbau hier liegt der Anteil
Deutschlands bei mehr als 70 Prozent
2300 deutsche Firmen haben
Tochterunternehmen oder Niederlassungen
im Land zum Beispiel besitzt VW 33
chinesische Werke für die Produktion von
Fahrzeugen und Komponenten und verkauft
über 40% seiner Autos dort
[Musik]
bei einem hoch würde nicht nur der
Umsatz für das deutsche Unternehmen
wegfallen sondern auch die chinesischen
Arbeitsplätze ebenso würde das
technologische Know-how aus Deutschland
fehlen ein Handelskrieg mit China wäre
ein Verlust für beide Seiten
ein Handelskrieg das kann also
wahrscheinlich niemand wollen Miriam wie
Kompromissbereitschaft durch China ein
ja die Kompromissbereitschaft der
politischen Führung einzuschätzen ist
gar nicht so einfach das ist in China
eine Blackbox was wirklich vor sich geht
ist gar nicht so einfach zu sehen vor
allem nicht was an staatschefie dem
Finger eigentlich wirklich rankommt er
hat ja gerade den Umbau vollendet also
alle seine Führungsgremien mit
vertrauten besetzt steht auf dem
Höhepunkt seiner Macht hat die
amtszeitbegrenzung aufgelöst strotzt
also vor Selbstbewusstsein und jetzt ist
China nach der corona-pause seit den
Lockerungen im vergangenen Jahr zurück
auf der Weltbühne und hier in Peking ist
gerade die Welt zu Gast in der
vergangenen Woche schon Japan Japan und
Spanien diese Woche ist die EU zu Gast
so geht es ja auch weiter und das ist
was was China natürlich sehr gefällt
also China strotzt davor
Selbstbewusstsein und ich glaube von
Kompromissbereitschaft kann man da nicht
sprechen aber wie was gerade im Beitrag
gehört haben natürlich ist China auch
abhängig also ich glaube die Führung
hier in Peking empfängt in erster Linie
ihren größten Handelspartner sie braucht
Europa vor allem als Absatzmarkt also
für ihre Handy wie es für ihre Computer
für ihre Spielzeuge da ist gerade weil
die weil die wirtschaftliche Lage im
Land so schlecht ist nach den drei
Jahren corona-politik ist China absolut
angewiesen auf Europa und braucht Europa
auch als Lieferanten vor allem von
Investitionen und von Know-how vor allem
im Hightech-Bereich also da gibt es ein
geben und nehmen diese Abhängigkeit ist
wechselseitig aber China stellt vor
allem mit diesem Besuch auch ins
Schaufenster wie gut die Beziehungen mit
Europa sind mit den USA läuft es ja
besonders schlecht gerade es gibt die
Sanktionen China versucht sich da immer
weiter abzugrenzen und zelebriert
natürlich dass die Welt zu Gast ist im
Peking und dass diese Beziehung zu
Europa so gut sind dass sie sie so
feiern können wie wir das morgen sehen
werden
zum Schluss noch die Frage an dich
Florian was wahrscheinlich ja nicht
danach aussieht also auch gerade nicht
nach dem Treffen von Putin und Chi sieht
nicht danach aus als hätte China vor
jetzt in russischen Angriffskrieg zu
verurteilen was ja etwas ist was aus
EU-Kreisen teilweise gefordert wurde wie
schätzt du die EU ein wird sie reagieren
wenn das also nicht kommt auch morgen
nicht kommt da also keinen Schritt
irgendwie aufeinander zugemacht wird in
diesem Punkt
tja man hat nicht viel in der Hand als
Europa es gibt hier immer so einen Wort
das durch die Debatte geistert eine
ziemlich radikale Idee das ist das Wort
der Entkopplung also der völligen
Loslösung von China jetzt haben wir
gerade gehört in wie vielen Fällen und
Bereichen Europa von China abhängig ist
und insofern ist dieses Wort diese Idee
wird hier von allen beiseite geschoben
eine völlige Entkopplung von China ist
völlig unrealistisch man würde sich ins
eigene Fleisch schneiden und das will
man auf keinen Fall tun was man aber tun
will ist das Risiko zu mindern und das
ist das neue Schlagwort der Stunde das
Gebot der Stunde sozusagen dass man
gerade in den sensitiven sensiblen
Bereichen in bei Rohstoffen die für die
Energiewende wichtig sind dass man sich
dort so unabhängig macht wie möglich von
China was aber sicherlich an Zeit
brauchen wird und diese Zeit ist die
Frage ob Europa sie hat jetzt wird man
sehen wie schnell und ob eben China
diese diese roten Linien überschreitet
aber jetzt ist glaube ich außerdem noch
wichtig zu wissen was wir auch am Anfang
der Sendung gehört haben von dem
EU-Außenbeauftragten Joseph Burrell am
Ende braucht man ja China für alle
globalen Herausforderungen vor allem
etwa für den Kampf gegen den Klimawandel
ohne China geht das nicht und das ist
eben die große Frage die große Balance
auch die Europa hier halten muss
einerseits unabhängig werden gewisse
klare Kante zu zeigen aber andererseits
auch den gesprächsfahrten nicht abreißen
zu lassen den globale Probleme brauchen
eben auch globale Antworten das geht nur
gemeinsam Europa die USA und eben auch
China danke für die Einschätzung Florian
neuhahn in Brüssel Miriam Steinmann
Peking vielen Dank
china will außerdem mit Handelspartnern
das können wir jetzt auch mal zeigen wie
Brasilien Südafrika Indien und eben
Russland ein Gegengewicht zum Westen
aufbauen und noch mehr Analyse in welche
Richtung die Beziehung zwischen China
und anderen Ländern und insbesondere
eben mit Europa wohin jetzt Steuern noch
mehr Analyse kann uns jetzt geben
Bernhard Bartsch von mercatorinstitut
für China Studien ist jetzt bei uns
schön dass Sie da sind hallo
hallo Herr Bartsch sie haben selbst
viele Jahre in Peking gelebt und zu
ihren Forschungsschwerpunkten gehören
die deutsche und europäische
China-Politik und die Herausforderungen
der wirtschaftlichen Verpflichtung da
kennen sie sich besonders gut aus sind
denn durch die Auswirkung eben das
russischen Krieges und auch Chinas
Positionierung dazu sind diese
Herausforderungen jetzt noch viel größer
geworden
ja die Herausforderungen sind größer
geworden und uns in Deutschland und
Europa ist bewusst geworden wie
politisch die Weltwirtschaft geworden
ist wie wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeiten
oder auch einfach
zulieferverhältnisse politisiert werden
können und da sind wir gerade dabei das
zu lernen dass das was wir früher für
relativ
harmlosen wirtschaftlichen Austausch
gehalten haben halt eine ganz
schwerwiegende geopolitische
Komponente hat die wir jetzt spüren und
mit Russland fühlen wir das bei Gas
jetzt gerade ganz konkret bei China sind
die verfechtungen viel tiefer viel
komplizierter aber wir haben es ja schon
gehört politisch ist China ein Land das
genauso bereit ist diese
wirtschaftlichen Abhängigkeiten bewusst
aufzubauen und bewusst politisch gegen
uns zu verwenden was das möchte und wer
braucht am Ende wenden mehr die EU China
oder umgekehrt was würden Sie sagen
wenn man so ganz groß betrachtet würde
ich sagen beide brauchen einander aber
das ist für die das konkrete politische
oder wirtschaftliche tun nicht so
entscheidend das geht um einzelne
Unternehmen zum Beispiel die natürlich
sehr darauf angewiesen sind entweder
nach China zu verkaufen oder aus China
bestimmte Produkte zu beziehen und da
wird das Bild dann sehr kompliziert wir
haben schon gehört bei bestimmten
Technologien in bestimmten Bereichen
brauchen wir einfach chinesische
Vorprodukte das ist nicht leicht das zu
ersetzen China braucht uns aber auch und
das ist so ein Bereich wo wir im Moment
uns anfangen durchzuarbeiten zu sehen
wie können wir Abhängigkeiten auf
unserer Seite verringern wie China auch
auf seiner Seite seit Jahren sehr viel
tut um Abhängigkeiten zu verringern und
so unwohl uns dabei ist die Amerikaner
sind dann natürlich mit viel härteren
Maßnahmen längs dabei wie können auch
wir die Abhängigkeiten die ich Ihnen von
uns hat durchaus politisch nutzen zum
Beispiel bei Mikrochips es gibt
Kommentare bei uns im Stream die ich
möchte immer zwei rausgreifen die gehen
so ein bisschen in ähnliche Richtung
User Hip Hop Guru schreibt er oder sie
sollte man vielleicht all den deutschen
Unternehmen mal auf die Finger hauen
also damit wird ja suggeriert nehme ich
mal an dass die die deutschen
Unternehmen da einfach gerne investieren
wollen und bindra schreibt Deutschland
fragt nie nach Menschenrechten in China
aber Geschäfte wollen sie ist das so
dass wir also einfach so gerne dort
Geschäfte machen wollen dass er
vielleicht auch manches dann doch nicht
so wichtig ist wie ja ist vielleicht
nach außen hingetan wird
das ist genau der Wandel den wir jetzt
gerade erleben und die Frage um das
aufzunehmen dass auf die Finger hauen
wenn man so nennt die Frage ist wer Haut
da wem auf die Finger wir sind und wie
sieht das tatsächlich praktisch aus wir
sind ja Gott sei Dank ein System wo
Unternehmen alleine entscheiden wo sie
investieren letztlich gerade um
kritische Produkte geht dann können
Unternehmen in China ihre Geschäfte
machen wie sie das wollen ohne
politische Einmischung das ist die Basis
unseres Wirtschaftssystems und das ist
auch gut so wir sind aber gerade dabei
zu merken dass wir bei bestimmten
Produkten bestimmten Technologien viel
vorsichtiger sein müssen ob sie zum
Beispiel militärisch verwendet werden
können wir sind dabei viel mehr auf
menschenrechtsbedingungen
hinzulieferketten zuschauen und wir sind
dabei die Rolle der Politik
grundsätzlich zu überdenken und dazu
gehört es wurde das Wort
schon angesprochen dass jetzt die
risking also Risikominderung das neue
Gebot der Stunde ist das ist völlig
richtig so dass man eben sich das
Risikos viel bewusster wird und
Unternehmen dazu bringt das tun die auch
selber von sich aus aber sie müssen da
auch ein wenig zu ermutigt und gedrängt
werden je größer sie sind die
systemische relevant sie für die
deutsche Wirtschaft sind umso mehr dass
sie sich genau anschauen was für Risiken
sie da haben und wie sich das auf uns
hier auswirken können
zwei User bei uns sind sich gemeinsam
auch wieder einer Meinung die möchte ich
auch gerne jetzt kurz da als Gegenfrage
stellen und zwar schreiben Susanne
peachic Petrovic bei Facebook so wie es
aussieht ist China für Deutschland
wichtiger Partner und nicht umgekehrt
und Jürgen Junker meint auf jeden Fall
ist China der größte Handelspartner der
EU und ich denke das wird China auch
bleiben würden sie das so unterschreiben
also das China im Zweifel wichtiger ist
sogar für Deutschland und dass das China
also besonders wichtig ist eben auch
diese in dieser Rolle zu bleiben
ich glaube china möchte dafür sorgen
dass es dass kein anderes Land für so
wichtig ist dass es dadurch seine eigene
Handlungsfähigkeit einschränkt
Deutschland ist wichtig für China als
Lieferant von bestimmten Technologien
China setzt wahnsinnig viel daran diese
Technologien entweder selbst
herzustellen oder Unternehmen
internationale Unternehmen dazu zu
bringen diese Technologien ein China zu
liefern im besten Fall in China mit
allem
Know-how auch selber dort zu produzieren
wir haben vorhin gehört dass China enorm
selbstbewusst ist und so tritt es
tatsächlich auf ich glaube wir dürfen
aber auch nicht überschätzen die
selbstbewusst ich China ist China hat
enorme Probleme wirtschaftlich läuft es
nicht gut gerade in China ist sich
seiner Schwächen bewusst in China ist
sich bewusst dass es sehr schwer wird
wenn sich ein internationaler breiter
eine breite Koalition gegen
weiterbilden würde ist zum Beispiel
abzuschneiden von bestimmten wichtigen
Technologien deswegen versucht China
gerade die Europäer zum Beispiel gegen
die Amerikaner oder auch gegen die
Japaner auszuspielen deswegen wird
macron der rote Teppich ausgerollt und
auch Ursula von der Leyen wird man
meiner Einschätzung nach viel
pfleglicher in den nächsten Tagen
behandeln als man es sonst getan hätte
nach der Rede die sie letzte Woche
gehalten hat jetzt reisen da ja genau
zwei miteinander also einmal Ursula von
der Leyen die die EU vertritt und einmal
der französische Staatschef kann man
überhaupt von einer einheitlichen
europäischen Linie Strategie sprechen
oder ist am Ende natürlich auch jedes
Land innerhalb der EU so ein bisschen
mit seinen eigenen Interessen da mehr
beschäftigt und hat er natürlich auch
eigene Aktien in China drin und möchte
die bestmöglich nutzen wie schätzen Sie
das ein wie einheitlich europäisch ist
denn diese Strategie
in der Analyse sind sich glaube ich alle
europäischen Länder inzwischen relativ
einig dass China eben
nicht nur ein Partner ist sondern auch
ein scharfer wirtschaftlicher
Wettbewerber und auch ein systemischer
Rivale der die Welt ändern will der
internationale Institutionen ändern will
der den globalen Wettbewerb verzerrt und
nach seinen eigenen Spielregeln neue
Formen will der Risiken sind sich alle
bewusst gleichzeitig ist China ein Land
in dem es immer noch wirtschaftliche
europäische Länder viel Geld zu
verdienen gibt und die Unternehmen
fordern natürlich politische Flankierung
ein die hat der deutsche Bundeskanzler
als erster europäischer Besucher nach
kovit
geleistet die leistet jetzt auch macron
wieder das ist ein Spannungsverhältnis
das da ist und deswegen ist diese
Reisegruppe die sich da gefunden hat
interessant
Ursula von sein als diejenige die das
die große Analyse
geliefert hat und die Risiken aufzeigt
und die Instrumente mit denen man in
Europa versuchen wird die Risiken zu
mindern und im manuellen macron der
natürlich auf der einen Seite zu Hause
als großer Europäer da stehen will aber
natürlich auch die wirtschaftlichen
Möglichkeiten die es in China ja nach
wie vor gibt nutzen will für seine
Unternehmen diese Spannungsverhältnis
wird es weitergeben und der
entscheidende Punkt wird sein die
Risiken darin ganz klar zu sehen und
viel viel bewusster sich zu sein als in
der Vergangenheit das halt man einen
hohen Preis dafür bezahlen kann in china
investiert zu sein
Florian neuhahn unser Korrespondent hat
es eben erwähnt also aktuell treffen
sich die NATO-Außenminister in Brüssel
zum ersten Mal nach dem Besuch zwischen
Chinas Staatschef und Präsident Putin
und hat China da jetzt keine Sorge also
auch nach diesen harten klaren Aussagen
von Jens Stoltenberg heute ist
Leutenberg heute dass ich eben das
Verhältnis zum Westen jetzt gerade
verschlechtet
China wird nie offen zeigen dass es
Sorgen hat China möchte
Selbstbewusstsein projizieren aber
natürlich macht das China sorgen in
China Wetter seit Jahren gegen die nahto
China
akzeptiert in all seinen offiziellen
Medien und staatlichen Äußerungen das
russische narrativ das ist der Westen
die USA die NATO gewesen sein die
Russland in diesen Krieg mit der Ukraine
gezwungen hätten das ist für Peking
wirklich eine ein bedrohliches Szenario
das ist ein breiten Schulterschluss
gegen China geben würde und dass der
sich jetzt
sicherheitspolitisch auch formt das in
Zukunft China in der NATO eine viel
größere Rolle spielen wird dessen wird
man sich in China erst so allmählich
bewusst aber das macht die chinesische
Position in keinster Weise leichter und
das macht China sicherlich auch große
Sorgen ohne das ist das offen zu geben
Markt hat er ja dann heute ich China
mehr oder weniger gewarnt also Waffen zu
liefern an Russland dass das Verhältnis
also so eng werden könnte dass das
passiert wie schätzen Sie das ein also
ist das Verhältnis so eng dass das im
Bereich des Möglichen wäre dass das
passiert
im Bereich des Möglichen ist das
deswegen wird so vehement dagegen
davor gefahren dass China jetzt auch
noch diese Grenze überschreiten sollte
Chinas Interessen in Russland sind
natürlich evident chitim Ping möchte
Putin Stärken er möchte dass Putin nicht
als völliger Verlierer aus diesem Krieg
eine ergeht denn China fährt mit Putin
sehr gut die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
nach Putin in Russland ein Präsident
regieren würde der so China freundlich
ist wie Putin ist relativ gering
deswegen wenn China diese Partnerschaft
stärken will die ist ja braucht um
letztlich eine globale
anti-westliche Allianz zu schmieden dann
braucht es dieses enge Verhältnis zu
Russland und möchte Russland da auch
militärisch und politisch wo es kann
stärken ohne allerdings
in eine totale Konfrontation mit dem
Essen zu gehen dieser Krieg in der
Ukraine ist auch für China ein großes
Problem China hätte es gerne wenn der
enden würde ohne das ist allerdings
dafür von Russland Seite weichen würde
ich möchte zum Schluss auch noch mal auf
einen Punkt eingehen habe ich gerade in
einem Kommentar auch gelesen von Heiko
Wernsdorf er schreibt als Meinung ich
glaube die EU hat die Entscheidung über
die Handelsbeziehung nicht mehr selbst
in der Hand wenn die USA ein
wirtschaftskonflikt mit China eingeht
muss Europa mitziehen und da finde ich
die Frage spannend ich habe es vorhin
auch angesprochen bevor wir beide unser
Gespräch gestartet haben also China
versucht ja schon ein Gegengewicht zum
Westen aufzubauen mit diesen
verschiedenen Handelspartnern auf der
ganzen Welt ist das als Gegengewicht
wirklich zum Westen gemeint also eben
auch zur EU oder eben vor allem als
Gegengewicht zu den USA
China sieht sich natürlich vor allem in
einem ganz grundsätzlichen
großmächtekonflikt mit den USA und
schaut sich aber die Welt darauf
hingehend an in welchem Lager sind denn
welche anderen
Mittelmächte die es gibt und da sehen
sie bei den Europäern natürlich dass wir
viel näher an den USA sind als in China
und Sie möchten aber vermeiden dass die
Europäer alles mitgehen was die
Amerikaner von den Europäern fordern und
diese dieses Tauziehen um Europa werden
wir in den nächsten Jahren noch noch
weiter erleben und letztlich ist klar wo
Europa steht das hat auch ursula von der
leidensrede noch einmal ganz klar
gemacht obwohl sie interessanterweise
nicht in der Rede letzte Woche direkt
auf die transatlantische Partnerschaft
eingegangen ist weil man natürlich in
Europa auch nicht sich völlig
vereinnahmen lassen will und noch eigene
Handlungsspielräume
austarieren möchte wir möchten aber
nicht um jeden Preis uns
unseren Kurs von Washington vorschreiben
lassen der ja auch seine seine eigenen
Irrationalitäten hat
insofern ist das ein Balanceakt den
Ursula von der Leyen hier versucht und
aufgezeichnet hat
wo wir da unser Balance Gefühl finden
müssen in den nächsten Jahren
ein Balanceakt den wir da morgen
beobachten können das sagt Bernhard
Bartsch vom mercator-institut für China
Studien danke dass Sie bei uns zu Gast
waren
danke
ein spannendes Treffen morgen dass wir
alle bestimmt beobachten werden erstmal
sage ich jetzt für heute vielen Dank vom
gesamten Team für eure Aufmerksamkeit
und wünsche euch einen schönen Abend bis
zum nächsten Mal tschüss